I am currently 29 years old and I've
never flown before hi I'm Jackie
tomorrow will be my first flight ever hi
I'm Jonathan and I will be hoping Jackie
on his first flight ever we work
together we've worked together for a
long time yes that's for not best
friends okay
we both need to go to LA he needs some
emotional support I don't need emotional
supports I could have done it myself he
would have been lost I would have been
fine you would have been I had Google
the reason I've never flown before is
I've never felt the need to everything
is within my fingertips if I wanted to
go try a different type of cuisine it
was literally across the block I think
it's the fear of the unknown yeah I
don't think he knows how he's gonna
react and so I think it's kind of built
up that way where it's like you know the
longer you put something off the more
afraid of the unknown you are I'm not
afraid I'm comfortable I'm comfortable
Unser no you know if he needs it no it's
fine
no I'm okay with that no I would say the
biggest things are TSA no knives no
liquids on the plane just like at 6:00
a.m. but like take a shot before you get
on and pass out I'll take the shot do
you know all I know is there is an
engine there is a bunch of jet feel and
it it's a giant metal box in the air I
have never actually written a ruler
technically yeah that's true why would I
need why would I need to oh my god
cursor why is that I think Oh Jackie if
the flight originally the flight there
goes terribly I will drive back but I
just want to point out he hasn't driven
in seven years either hello Jackie good
morning how's it feeling this early you
excited to fly I guess
are you
[Music]
jaci figuring it out
[Music]
see Jackie they make it idiot her no
check-in for me too
[Music]
so what do you think about the
experience in general Jackie
[Music]
it's just a lot of people going on look
at this Lina's massive line
see how it's STS a pre and then you see
this line and there is no line what do
you think about that how long did it
take to get through security all right
what do you think of the whole process
huh I feel very secure so I just want to
let you know that like if you ever go
flying again this will not be the
general terminal Jackie first airport
donut
how's your person Airport food tastes
alright Jackie we're getting on the
plane come on man let's be excited you
got this
[Music]
how do you feel like you get some of
that DirecTV 13 going on 30
you know no he embraced it no one's
judging it's your time to watch whatever
you want then
are you
and we're slowly moving
[Music]
that was the first
yeah
[Music]
this is turbulence Jackie
[Music]
first light
how does it feel to be on the entire
opposite end of the country
difference would you ever fly yet you
don't have a choice
[Music]
do you feel like a cowboy right now
Jackie how does it feel Jackie no big
deal when I'm behind the wheel
[Music]